des règles depuis beyrouth avec françois
el bacha économise fondateur de linda
linda news c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir françois el
bacha merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france on vous a vu vous exprimer
un dans ce reportage
l'enquêté ouverte par le parquet
national financiers s'ajoute à deux
plaintes déposées au uk et au liban les
taux clairement se resserre autour de
riad salamé soir c'est pas au liban au
liban il ya une enquête effectivement
mais c'est en suisse et en angleterre au
libor la plainte concerne plutôt disons
voir c'est le scandale de la
manipulation du cours de la livre
libanaise où il y a aussi maintenant une
ouverture d'une enquête à la demande de
la justice française va justice suisse
donc oui je vous en prie devant coeur
riad salamé le gestionnaire de fortune
de rafic hariri qui l'a nommé par la
suite à la tête de la banque centrale
libanaise cela clermont ne pose pas un
problème de conflit d'intérêts
effectivement cela cela fait envie d'en
tirer puisque la famille hariri poster
10% des actions de toutes les banques
libanaises donc qu'on peu peur mon art à
la fois un juge et un arbitre dans ce
cas là et 43% de la peau des hommes de
la classe politique est impliqué aussi
dans dans l'actionnariat des banques
libanaises et donc automatiquement le
parlement est aussi partie prenante au
détriment de l'intérêt des déposants par
exemple et on a perdu herman la loi sur
le contrôle des capitaux on voit bien
que les que les parlementaires ont
pratiquement tout déléguer comme tout ce
qui est décisionnel à la banque du liban
c'est clairement l'illustration l'image
de la corruption qui règne dans le pays
depuis déjà plusieurs années
il y a de fortes chances que la banque
du liban un audit jolie comptables de la
banque du liban le révèle certaines
choses certaines zones en asie on peut
parler pour le moment d'anomalies on
peut pas parler réellement de
détournement de fond ça c'est l' enquête
qui développe qui le déterminera
mais autant qu'on sache s'il ya
certaines anomalies déjà sur le plan
comptable par rapport à l'audi normal
qui a été publiée la calcule ce qui a
été publié l'année dernière de ses
comptes
les libanais en tout cas l'accusant riad
salamé d'être carrément responsables de
la crise économique qui frappe durement
le pays
ces accusations vous semble-t-elle
recevable ça oui ça il ya c'est
quelqu'un qui reste et depuis très
longtemps la tête de la banque grid ans
c'est lui qui a formulé la politique
monétaire de la banque dont on est dans
une crise aujourd'hui qui
essentiellement financières c'est
simplement le fait d'avoir gardé une
monnaie surévaluée pendant 25 ans sans
aucun ajustement sans aucune dévaluation
progressive de la libanaise pour
justement attirer des fonds de
l'étranger pour conserver des fonds de
l'étranger et ainsi de suite et jusqu'à
ce que le système s'effondre de lui-même
certains hommes politiques étrangers
comme emmanuel macron lors de son
déplacement au liban n'ont pas hésité à
parler de schéma ponzi qu'un schéma de
fraude en fin de compte et ça c'est du
ressort de la banque du liban mais il
faut quand même rappeler effectivement
que sa fortune dépasserait les 2
milliards de dollars alors qu'on ne sait
rien des pires crises économiques que
connaît le pays
aujourd'hui on imagine qu'il va y avoir
beaucoup de pression sur ces enquêtes
qui pèsent sur lui
il ya deux ans dans une main pendant
local et un pendant internationale le
pendant local jusqu'à maintenant on n'a
pas réussi à marcher
simplement parce que la justice
libanaise est très politisée com
le boire dans le reportage c'est une
injustice qui avait déjà été paralysé
l'année dernière dans le cadre des
enquêtes sur la manipulation du cours de
la livre libanaise dans le cadre d'un
contrôle informel des capitaux par des
banques on avait les banques qui ont
mené pour critère des banques qui ont
menacé de faire grève et grosso modo le
procureur de la république à annuler la
décision du procureur financier de
saisie et de nez bien le sait que ses
actionnaires donc et on espère que
grosso modo la lanque est un passionné
elle va pouvoir faire pression sur le
système judiciaire local pour débloquer
des choses fois ci de manière beaucoup
plus efficace mais qu'on lui a mis la
pression sur les dirigeants libanais et
pourtant rien ne semble bouger ça veut
dire quoi que la voix du président
français n'a aucun impact au liban on
est dans un système où il ya beaucoup de
résistance et ces gens là pensent être
beaucoup plus puissants même que la
communauté internationale mais dense
dans les équations actuelle si la
communauté internationale qui détient
toutes les cartes en main on a une
situation où nuque au bord d'un
effondrement économique
on ne les banques seulement un rapport
standard reste en une porsche ou est-ce
que face à des pertes de 100 milliards
de dollars 143,2 milliards de dollars de
dépôts il n'y a aucun moyen aujourd'hui
à ce que le système bancaire puisse
survivre à long terme on voit juste
qu'ils essaient simplement de gagner du
temps comme en donnant 400 dollars par
mois aux déposants en cash en devises
étrangères et quelle est l'équivalent de
400 $ en livres libanaises au taux de la
banque du liban
c'est à dire de la nouvelle plateforme
électronique d'abord du liban mais cela
augmente la masse monétaire et donc
provoquer cette détérioration de la
libye et ban est ils n'ont aucune marge
de manoeuvre
mais ils veulent pas l'admettre
clairement aujourd'hui riad salamé son
avocat estime qu'il s'agit c'est qu'il
s'agit d'une manipulation et d'une
opération politique
est-ce qu'on peut réellement le croire
on entend beaucoup parler de choses
il ya même des gens qui prétendent que
la justice suisse où la justice
française voulait justice anglaise voire
même la justice américaine se fait
manipuler par des partis politiques
libanais comme le hezbollah
ça serait très étonnant que le hezbollah
qui fait l'objet de sanctions
économiques puissent manipuler
c'est l'appareil judiciaire français un
appareil judiciaire suit son appareil
d'une serre même américain donc décevoir
laissons les choses faire leurs courses
hui leurs cours déterminer des
responsabilités de chacun et on verra
bien si effectivement la justice
française ouvre une enquête
c'est qu'il ya des événements quand même
qu'ils sont assez troublant comme la
justice suisse merci beaucoup à françois
el bacha économistes fondateur de
limonade news d'avoir été avec nous